Today is the last day for the coupon code.
Twenty, twenty now. I think you all know
why. Grab a membership, but join Pacman.
ARCOM save 66 percent, 66 percent illegal,
I hear in some states. Just kidding.
Twenty, twenty now is the coupon code. Grab
a membership. Countries around the world and
the United States in including United States
universities and police departments and mayors and
others are saying be very careful in the United
States in the aftermath of today's election. There
are real credible, serious preparations being made
and warnings issued about violence that
is expected as we learned the results of
tonight's election. There are many scenarios in
which I expect violence, and they are basically
every scenario other than a blowout win by
Joe Biden. If Joe Biden wins, but it's close.
And Trump claims it was rigged or fraudulent,
his followers will go crazy in the streets. I
hate that this is likely, but it is if Trump wins,
but by a little bit. But he does so by stopping
absentee ballot counting or through other tricks.
I think we will see both sides in the streets,
the left protesting for fair elections and trump
ists with their guns. If Trump claims victory,
but then as absentee votes of votes are counted,
it starts to shift in the direction of Joe Biden.
Fired up lunatic Trump lists will be all over the
streets and it's going to be insane. And in fact,
reporters from Reuters are being equipped as if
they were covering a war. I will get to that a
little bit later. It's not just me talking
about it and others in the political space.
George Washington University in Washington,
DC told its students stockpile food stock
pile medications, as you normally would before a
hurricane or a snowstorm during which you might be
home for several days. The Texas Army National
Guard is prepared to deploy to the state's largest
cities starting today. Police departments across
the country are getting their officers ready for
unrest or disruptions at the polls or after the
polls. Businesses in many cities are boarding
up ahead of Election Day to prevent glass
breaking incidents and maybe even worse.
And stunningly, the state departments of
other countries are telling their citizens,
be very careful in the United States, avoid
the United States. If you can check this out
from the New Zealand's safe travel government
agency, they put out a statement saying, quote,
New Zealanders in the United States are
advised to avoid areas where political
rallies or protest activity may occur. We
recommend monitoring local media to stay
up to date with developments and following any
instructions issued by the local authorities,
including curfews. If you find yourself in an area
of protest, political activity or civil unrest,
you should leave the area. If it is safe to do so
or remain indoors until the situation improves,
they are providing New Zealanders with emergency
contacts at embassies and consulates. Should the
manure hit the fan and should they need help? The
FBI has been briefed for contingencies depending
on what goes down and how crazy things get.
By the way, to go back to New Zealand. If
I lived in New Zealand, the last place I'd be
thinking of going right now is the United States,
short of an absolute emergency that
required me to be in the United States.
Australia issuing similar warnings. The
Department of Foreign Affairs and Trade
updating its advice, saying there is a potential
for violence in the coming days and weeks in the
US. Australian travelers should stay away, saying
also that the risk of terrorism has increased.
Quote, The U.S. has a heightened risk of terrorist
attacks. Terrorists may use vehicles, knives,
homemade bombs, poisons or toxins. Be alert,
particularly in public places and at events.
Violent crime is more common in the U.S. than
in Australia, and gun crimes are possible in all
areas. It's like coming into a war zone the way
these countries are warning their citizens about
being in the United States tonight and later into
this week. So in the end, here's my bottom line.
Trump landslide win. Expect large protests
against Trump to collide with pro Trump protesters
celebrating a Trump narrow win under questionable
circumstances. Expect absolutely unprecedented
protests colliding with pro Trump protesters. A
Biden narrow win with Trump claiming foul play
is the scariest scenario to me, where you will
have the same Trump people out but furious rather
than happy as they would be if Donald Trump were
to win. And then again, on a Biden landslide to me
as. The safest from a public unrest standpoint, I
think a landslide win for Biden will so demoralize
Trump and his followers that it's the most
likely scenario in which they stay home.
And slowly over the next four years, start to
pretend they never really supported Donald Trump
anyway. So those are the warnings. That's law
enforcement, that's departments of State and the
like. Net. Let's now talk about what's going on
for reporters planning to cover today's election